vou contar um segredo não só três não
estou sentindo aquele frio na barriga
que os atores sente ao entrar em cena só
regina mãe avó e amiga
eu não tenho muito estudo este com
diploma e formatura
eu tenho aquele outro que aos 68 anos de
idade
a vida foi me ensinando pois bem
a maior dificuldade que eu encontro
todos os dias é a falta da visão do
coletivo cada um olhando para o seu
próprio umbigo
hoje desde que eu comecei a trabalhar
com artesanato
é muita gente olhando só para o seu
próprio trio sempre me empenhei em
difundir o trabalho coletivo e os
benefícios que ensino estágios mas hoje
já sei que é longo êsse processo aprendi
isso as duras penas da faculdade da vida
o dar um exemplo se uma moça alguns anos
atrás que aqui vou chamar de estela
parecia muito orgulhosa egoísta
um dia num evento que estavam se ouvia
falar mal de um colega não me segurei
ou seja a corda armada em aí depois de
viver conviver bastante com ela observei
que ela ela menosprezada pelo marido
ele é até carinhoso com ela mas não
convidava para os trabalhos sociais e
realizarmos com isso ela se sentia muito
diminuída quando percebi isso comecei a
criar situações a envolvê la no trabalho
e ganhar desabafou
ela então foi vivendo um longo processo
de cruzar o muro devido à lígia que se
descobriu com um artesão de grande
talento foi trabalhar com bill joy é
hoje uma pessoa uma mulher agregadora
estou contando a história das telinha
para que vocês pensem comigo
quantas vezes telas estão presas nos
seus lábios lavando passando cruze ano
cuidando dos filhos mas querendo voar
assim como estela
todas têm que conhecer uma rede
lembra que eu falei que a minha escola é
a vida pois havia me aprontou 11 uma
prova forte de verdade quando eu tinha
pensa 18 anos eu fui parar no fundo do
poço e qual foi a minha sorte tinha
pessoas tinha pessoas do meu lado quer
cuida de cuidado da gente não é já eram
em pessoas que abraçaram a causa de toda
a pessoa que precisasse
e qual foi a minha sorte tinha o meu
lado gente que se importava com a gente
uma rede de verdade eu fui resgatada
devagarinho com amor e carinho como eu
precisava e põe neste processo que eu
ganhei meu maior tesouro descobrir que
eu tenho um dom e após picada 1 nessa
sala também tem mas eu descobri meu
naquele momento do furto do posto ea
partir dali passei a cuidar mais dele eu
tenho o dom
o talento de conseguir trabalhar em rede
em rede de pessoas olho-no-olho mão na
mão
desde os meus 18 anos eu desenvolvo um
trabalho coletivo de artesões onde
muitas vezes têm a oportunidade de
resgatar mulheres que como eu levar uma
trombada da vida
esse talento de reunir pessoas que digo
que tem tenho mesmo vocês podem
acreditar
vou falar só de um aprendizado aprendi a
ouvir e ser ouvida
isso é fundamental para o sucesso do meu
negócio
o dar um exemplo há muitos anos atrás
numa feira e chegou uma senhora com a
menina pelas mãos da menina pixon olhar
no objeto e falou no vídeo da mãe eu
curiosa
você quer me dizer alguma coisa está
faltando algo naquela bruxinha o que
elimina tá faltando nada aí o meu
talento sussurrou no meu ouvido ou viu
que a menina está dizendo ouvir
ela só disse tá faltando a bola de
cristal
caramba como eu fazia aquela bruxa tanto
tempo e não tinha percebido que minha
bruxa não podia fazer adivinhações
ela não tinha um instrumento ea partir
dali minhas bruxa todas ganharam bolas
de cristal e fez tanto sucesso que se
tornou meu carro chefe de venda
aquela menininha trabalhou em rede
comigo e quase que eu perca esta
oportunidade por não querer ouvir até
hoje é meu carro chefe por causa daquela
pequena rede que nós três irmãos eu ela
e a bruxinha essas bruxinha elas são tão
dá nada tão poderosa e às vezes
aprontando das suas
teve uma vez que eu estava no
criatividade sem limite não é na ufrj
quando um estudante pegou bruxinha pela
mão era lina roupa preta cabelos pretos
mechas douradas enquanto custo
ele estava olhando com tanto carinho a
bruxa que eu disse
enquanto tu me oferece
negócio fechado
fiquei tão feliz por ele que acabei
fazendo uma profecia
quando a moça que receber esse presente
que abrir esse pacote e vê esta bruxinha
ela vai te agarrar pelo pescoço e tê-las
cambridge nem eu acreditei que falei
aquilo
o menino e olhou sério pegou as duas
bruxas dan pacote com as duas mãos se
foi no outro mês no primeiro dia de
feira
quem aparece o garoto da profecia veio
me contar que a menina moça bruxinha
desde então estão junto da morana os 3
ele ela e a bruxinha trabalho em rede
cada bruxa que eu faço recebe um pedaço
de mim ali tem a minha paz tem meu amor
à minha fidelidade e uma pitadinha da
minha força vencedora a bruxa é a minha
marca real e este ano na minha
felicidade e alegria de todas as
bruxinhas que já fiz e ainda parei
acabo de receber a minha primeira
logomarca aos 50 anos de profissão
você já viu que eu tenho mania de dar
exemplo e tudo que falam né pois a
partir de agora quando eu falar em rede
mudar os nossos exemplo nós estamos
trabalhando em rede aqui eu contando a
minha história e vocês generosamente me
dando a sua atenção
é uma rede de verdade o olho no olho
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]